let's get
back to
space complexity um so what
uh just to review what we've been doing
um
from last lecture which
feels like a long time ago but it was
only two days ago
um we
were looking at um
those three theorems
which all had this basically the same
proof
one was the latter about the latter
problem of uh where you're trying to see
if you can get from one
string to another string
changing one symbol at a time
um and all of the strings were in the
language of some finite automaton or you
had some reasonable rule for
saying which of the valid strings which
are not
and then uh we built on that idea we
showed savage's theorem that going from
any non-deterministic machine to a
deterministic machine only squares the
amount of space
and then um
we finally
uh proved that tqbf uh this problem
about quantified boolean formulas
testing whether they are true
uh that that problem is complete
for p space um so we're going to build
off of that last last theorem today
and talk about
uh
one other
complete problem um and also
show a connection between
p space
and testing uh which side uh
can win in certain kinds of games
um
so um and then the at the end of the
lecture we will the second half of the
lecture we'll talk about
diving deeper into space complexity
we're going to talk about a different
part of the parameter space where
instead of looking at polynomial space
we're going to talk about what happens
if you have logarithmic space which is
another natural
point to look at for from
for space complexity but we'll get to
that after the after the break
okay um
uh talk about game complexity and games
um
so when i was little uh we used to play
me and my sisters would play a game
called geography i don't know if how
many of you have heard it or maybe it go
goes under a different name um
but uh
it was a game about basically about
words and places and it has a very
simple um
set of rules um let's say there were two
people you take turns picking
names of places
and then each person
has to pick a place
which starts with the letter that the
previous person's place ended with
for example
you know you have two people playing um
perhaps you have you know you agree on
some starting place like a major city
nearby like boston
um so one you know one player the first
player takes boston
and then after that the next player has
to pick a place that starts with n
because boston ends with n
and so maybe nebraska
would be a possible response to boston
and then the first player would have to
respond to that with a place that starts
with an a because nebraska ends with an
a it's like maybe alaska
uh which also
starts with a ends with a
so
then arkansas maybe would be a nat
reasonable response to that and then
that ends with s um so uh san francisco
and then so on and so on um
and uh
of course you want to
forbid people from
reusing
names because then you'll just get into
a loop you know saying alaska alaska
alaska won't make the game very
interesting so you have to forbid
that possibility
names cannot be reused they can be used
at most once
and then um so eventually
one side or the other is going to run
out of names uh and not have a either
because of the lack of their
geographical knowledge or maybe you've
just exhausted all the possibilities
and i will will not have a response and
that person will be stuck and that
person is the loser um the other person
has won the game
so the objective is to try to avoid
getting stuck um so let's just take a
look um i'm going to think about that
games in a somewhat
slightly more abstracted formalized way
um so you write down all of the
legitimate places um they become nodes
of a graph such as i've shown here
and then you draw an edge from one node
to another if um that
if that corresponds to a legal move in
the game a legal step of the game so you
know boston connects to places that
start within like new york and nebraska
um so the first person might pick boston
the second person might pick either of
these two um and then back to the first
person if they pick nebraska they could
pick arkansas they can pick alaska and
so on just as i described
believe it or not
we actually played this game i can
remember playing this game when i was a
kid that was of course before we had um
uh
you know league of legends and other fun
fun stuff but this is what kids used to
do uh
so
anyway um
um
so just to
get it down on the slide the rules are
we'll assume we have two players we'll
call them player one and player two
player one goes first
um and they take turns picking places
that start with the letter which ended
the previous place
not no repeats allowed and the first
person players the first player stuck
loses
you know the person who doesn't have a
move to make
so what we're going to look at
um today is a generalized version of
that where we're kind of um just going
to take away the names but just leave
the underlying graph
and we're going to call that generalized
geography so here um that can be played
on any directed graph you take away
the names of the edges the names of the
nodes now you just have a some arbitrary
graph
um you're going to designate a
particular node as the starting node and
then the players take turns following
those edges
um and uh what uh you're
because you're gonna forbid having any
loops reusing any um any nodes uh what
you end up
doing is working together you're going
to be constructing a simple path in that
graph
simple path just follows those edges and
never intersects itself
and the first person the first player to
be stuck is the loser so the other one
is the winner okay so that's we're going
to call that generalized geography and
we're going to look at the computational
complexity of deciding for a given graph
and starting point
which side would win if both
uh players
played
optimally as best uh the best possible
okay
and we'll name that problem gg or look
at its associated language so here is a
graph and the starting node
and you want to say um
that pair is in
the language gigi
if the first player player one
who must play at that node a um to start
off with has a forced win
um
uh
in that
general geography game on that graph
starting at a okay where again what i
mean by a force when i'm not going to
define this formally that we could do
that it's not hard to do but a forced
wind also it's also called a winning
strategy
um that just means that if both sides
play optimal they pay the best possible
not up their capability i mean the
absolutely the best possible play
then that
player one
would still win there's nothing that
player two can do to prevent player one
from winning um if player one has a
winning strategy or a forced win um you
may have seen for example uh
there are examples of this that
i mean i don't even know if they still
exist but it used to be in the newspaper
they used to be examples of chess boards
and they would say you know if they
would start from a certain position and
they would say white to win in three
and so that means white has a forced win
no matter what black does white is going
to end up winning but you have to think
of what the strategy is it may not be so
obvious to think through what are the
right moves that what makes but the
point is that no matter what black would
do white would end up winning um and
what you can show we're not going to do
that but for
a class of games that includes this
generalized geography
either one side or the other is going to
be guaranteed to have a forced win
that's not necessarily true for all
possible games obviously
but for a large class of games um
in one side or the other
is guaranteed to have a winning strategy
or forced win
okay
so let's just review that because this
is going to be essential for
you know the first half of the lecture
to understand what we mean by a game and
what we mean by one side or the other to
have a force to win okay so let's let's
just uh oh yeah and what we're going to
show is that gg is piece based complete
that the problem of giving one of these
graphs and a starting point figuring out
does player 1 have a force win or is it
player 2 that has a force win
um
which side is guaranteed to win under
optimal play that's a piece based
complete problem
um
and so let's do a little checking on
that and so i'm going to give you a very
small example
of the generalized geography game
you have to figure out
whether it's player one or player two
that has the forced win the winning
strategy or maybe neither or both those
are the four options okay and you
understand player one has to play here
because that's the starting place of
this general geography game so then it's
up to player two to continue on
all right so let's um launch that poll
uh you'll have to think about it a
little bit um
and uh
let me know what you think which side
has a forced win
which player makes the first move it's
player one makes the first move and
player one plays as i showed you here
this is player one playing at a so
player one picks a
picks and then player two has to pick
one of these two
okay all right i think we're gonna end
the poll
everybody's in
pick something
um
you you guys did not do well on this
bowl
uh at least not too many of you picked
d
that's that's true that's a that's a
little reassuring because you can't have
both players having a forced win
i did say that in games of this kind one
side or the other is going to have a
force win so c is not a very good choice
either um
so you're
maybe you should spend less time reading
your email and more time listening to
the lecture uh
um
the actual correct answer is b
player two
um which is obviously a is a minority
position here player two has the forced
win let's understand why um
so
player one plays here
as i said that's the b that's the first
move player two can either take the
upper
node or the lower note
okay
player two takes the upper note
then player one has no choice but to
take the rightmost node
and now there's no move for player two
uh so player two will lose
um if player two takes the upper note
the upper choice there because
player two will go here player one will
go there and it'll be game over
and player one will have one because
player two was stuck
however
player two had another choice
um
uh player two had another choice um
player two could have also gone down
here
um so player two uh if it played down
here um
things are looking a lot better for
player two because player two goes here
player one's move is forced goes here
but now there's another move left uh
that player two could make so play
player so two goes here one goes there
player two goes up there
and now player one is stuck
so at player two's choice
um player two can make a move which will
end up
causing player one to get stuck
and so because
it you know that's the nature of what we
mean by uh having a winning strategy
there is some way to guarantee if you're
playing optimally and you're certainly
playing optimally mean you'll take that
lower move
uh
then you will
take that so
under
uh optimal play
player two will win this game
and so player two has a winning strategy
it has a forced win
okay
um so i i see so
i'm not going to define playing
optimally i'm going to you know there's
some questions here about that about
that that's um
you know you can think about
i'm going to i'm going to leave it
um
you know
somewhat informal um but we could make
that all precise i i don't think it
would be clarifying to to go through a
precise definition of that um
uh
you know you you can just think you we
don't even have to think about it in
terms of optimal play you you can say
that there is um
a uh forever
uh a
um
you say a player has a force win
if
uh
they have moves that they could make in
response to every possible move the
opponent could make
uh that'll guarantee that they will end
up winning
so it doesn't say we don't even have to
talk about optimality here just talk
about every possible opponent
every possible opponent is going to lose
to somebody who um
uh
you know
has a has a winning strategy and pl and
follows that strategy
okay um
okay i can see there was some confusion
about who was going first and so on i'm
glad we that was part of the reason i
gave this check and just so hopefully to
clear up some of those points um so
player one plays here then player two uh
goes and i got some comments that some
people were confused about what does it
mean for the first uh
where does the first person move okay
hopefully that's
that's uh
clear all right so let's move on
because we're gonna make we're gonna be
spending a while
um
proving something about generalized
geography and these graphs
um okay so let's let's continue
so in order to make a connection
between
um games
and complexity
we're going to need to
talk about a problem one that we've
actually related to one that we've
already seen where we can reformulate
that problem as a game and that's going
to be a problem on quantified boolean
formulas called the formula game
okay so this is a different game now um
not one that you're likely to end up
playing but in in in in a sense in which
you'll see this is a still a reasonable
game where two players can play against
one another and one of them is going to
end up winning and one of them is going
to end up having
uh
one or the other will have a winning
strategy so let's understand what the
game is
uh the game is played
the game is played on a formula
so you so you write down a quantified
boolean formula remember we talked about
that you know for several lectures now
uh you know it's a bunch of quantum
variables with quantifiers
and um
then there's the part that has no
quantifiers
um which
you know uh you can always put into
conjunctive normal form if you want but
for the purposes of this discussion so
far it doesn't matter later on we'll
actually want it to be in quant in
in cnf but okay but but for now we just
have some formula
[Music]
and
associated to that formula there is a
game in a very natural sense so first of
all let me they're going to be two
players
but now the names of those players are
going to be player exist and player for
all
okay and the way the way this is how the
game goes
the uh
the player exists
but both players are going to be picking
values for variables
they're going to say
you know variable x1 is true variable x2
is false variable x3 is false variable
x4 is true
and and they're going to be that that's
how the moves of the game go
they're just assigning values to
variables
so that in the end
all of the variables have been assigned
a value a boolean value and so we end up
with an assignment
but
before we get to that stage
which players get to pick
which variables and the way it works is
the exist player is going to assign
values to the exist variables
so exist we'll pick x1 and x3 and assign
them val values
the for all player is going to pick the
very ver assigned values to the
variables that have referral quantifier
attached
so in this case would be x2 would be um
the the the for all player will pick the
value for x the x2 variable
um fading out here
okay
now um so
and the order of play is
according to the order of the appearance
of the quantifiers in the formula
so the way i have it written out in this
particular formula it's exist x1 so
exist will pick the value for x1
then it's for all's turn for all pick
the value of x2 then it's going to be
exist picking the value for x3
and and so on until they get to the end
and all of the variables have been
assigned a value by one side or the
other
and now the game is over
okay
so
what's left is to understand who has won
at that point
um
and the way we
say who has won is
exist
wins
if in the end
this part psi
which is the part without quantifiers
ended up being satisfied by those
um by that assignment that the two
players together ended up picking
and then for all
will
win
if that
part of the formula is not satisfied
so let me just write that down here
after the variables have been assigned
values we determine the winner
exist wins if the assignment that they
co-op together built they built
cooperatively together uh satisfied psy
and otherwise for all ones if it doesn't
satisfy psi okay so you kind of think
about it this way
you know exist is picking the values of
those variables
he's trying to make
this
uh part of the formula satisfied trying
to satisfy this part of the formula for
all
is picking values but she's trying to
make this part of the formula
unsatisfied so they're
you know they're uh in opposition to one
another
and
um in the end one of them is going to
have succeeded and the other one will
have failed uh
and now thinking about it as a game
one side depending upon the formula one
side or the other is going to have the
ability to dominate the other one and
always win
um
and so
the question is
which side has that um ability to always
win which side has the winning strategy
of course it'll depend upon the formula
some formulas it'll be the exist player
who has the winning strategy and other
formulas it'll be the for all player who
has the winning strategy and
computationally we'd like to make that
determination which side is going to win
um
you know for a given formula
and there's a very very nice
and actually very easy
um and simple way to understand that
because we've already run into that
problem before
the problem of determining which side
has a force force win is exactly the
same thing as determining whether this
quantified boolean formula is true
because the exist player has a force win
when that formula game on that um on
that formula
um
let me say it again the exist player has
a force win when that formula is true
um
so if this quantified boolean formula
were a true quantified bullying formula
then exist is guaranteed to be able to
win that game if it if it plays
its hand right
if this is a false formula for all the
for all player will always be able to
win um if it plays its hand right
okay so um why is that
and it really follows kind of almost
you know without doing any work at all
this is kind of a you know
this proof even though it looks
superficially like it might be not so
easy to prove
it follows for a very simple reason
because
the meaning of what it means for exist
to have a winning strategy is exactly
captured by the semantics of the
quantifiers
let's see what that means what does it
mean that exists has a force to win
let's say up here
that means that well exist has a move
that it could make
that
exists can
pick some value for x1 so there was some
move for x for there was some way to
assign x1
so that no matter what the opponent does
no matter what for all does
there's going to be a response that it
exists can make um some some assignment
to it x3
um
uh so that no matter what for all does
there's going to be an assignment to the
next variable
um and so on and so on so that this
thing ends up being true
so let me just say that again somehow i
didn't feel it came out very clear
uh so
exist has a winning strategy exactly
when there was some assignment to x1
that exists can make such that no matter
what assignment that for all makes to x2
there is some assignment to x3
um such that no matter what assignment
that um for all makes to x4
and so on
makes this thing true
that's what it means for exist to have a
winning strategy
that's exactly what the quantifiers are
saying in the first place
so even really without doing anything
you can see that exists has a winning
strategy
means exactly the same thing as the
formula the quantified being formula
being true
so making the test of whether
uh which side has a winning strategy is
the same as testing whether the formula
is true
okay um
[Music]
so let's let me try to turn to the chat
now um before before we move on to
anything else
um
all right uh whoops
uh here we go
[Music]
okay so i'm getting some questions about
the order of play and about the
alternation of the quantifiers here
so the way i'm showing it
is that the quantifiers always alternate
exist for all exists for all that
doesn't really matter
you know you could have several exists
in a row and that would correspond to
exist making several moves in a row
before turning it over to parole
but
alternatively
we could just add extra variables which
don't play any role in psi
and um they're just kind of dummy
variables that serve as spacers so if
you have two exists in a row and you
don't like that you can just add add a
for all of some variable that you never
see again in between
so you can always get it to be
alternating if you want
so
um
um
also question the difference between pha
fee
uh and psi so psi is the part here that
does not have any quantifiers
so the way we always write down our qbfs
is their leading quantifiers with the
variables which
uh you know and all variables have to be
within the scope of one of the
quantifiers of quantified variables um
so you know there are no free variables
that are unquantified in our qbfs
um and so there's a you know all of
these qbfs have a run of quantifiers and
then a part without quantifiers where
there's this sort of boolean logic part
i'm psi here is the boolean logic part
and phi is the whole thing together with
the quantifiers
um
so
i'm not sure i understand some of these
ques why not have the for all player
have a force to win the for all player
might have a full force win no see
one side or the other is guaranteed to
have a forced win so if exist does not
have a force to win then then parole
will have a forced win that you know i'm
not going to prove that but that's a
fairly simple proof by induction which
i'm not going to go through just take it
as a fact
somebody's asking why does for all want
to not satisfy the uh this expression
the the psy part well i mean that's the
way we set up the game um
you know in order to make this
correspond to tqbf
um
just the truth
of the of this
of this expression we want to make exist
try to satisfy the the this part and for
all try to
unsatisfy make it not satisfied um
and so i'm not sure
because that's what works i'm not sure
what else whatever whether why i can
answer there okay somebody
i'm going to answer some of the you know
most basic questions here somebody's
asking how do we know how many variables
to use
so the
the variables are the variables of the
formula so somebody's going to hand you
a formula
that's going to have x1 to x10 whatever
that formula has some number of
variables and so that game is going to
have 10 moves
you know if the quantifiers alternate
then the moves will alternate but
whatever the pattern of the quantifiers
is going to be the pattern of the moves
so exist is going to follow the
um
you know the places where the exist
quantifier occurs and fraud is going to
follow the places where the for all
quantifier occurs so if you have you
know exist for all exist for all exist
will move first then for all move then
exist will move then for all will move
together they're picking values to their
respective variables with with their
opposing goals
existed trying to make the
um the psi part satisfied for all is
trying to avoid making it satisfied to
make to to make make the assignment not
satisfy that part
and if you think about what that means
just in terms of the meaning of that
that it's going to mean exactly the same
thing that the formula is true
um
so
anyway if you don't
let's see i don't know if there's any
more questions that i can try to answer
here
um
well
so it's still about the numbers of
variables the
um
each formula is going to define a
different game you see the formula
so the formula however big it may have
50 variables that may have two variables
but we'll do an example maybe that'll
help
um
the next check-in which is coming up for
pretty soon might actually be now uh
we'll give you an example
um so then we'll
see who's who's understanding and who's
not okay so let's continue here
um
so
so therefore the problem of determining
does exist have a force win is exactly
the tqbf problem because exist has a
force when exactly when the formula is
true
and what we're going to show is that t
qbf
is
a polynomial time reducible to
generalized geography
but it's conceptually we're going to
think about tqbf now as a game because
that's how geography is generally
geography is set up
so we're going to given a formula like
this we're going to construct an
instance of generalized geography we're
going to construct a graph
where play on that graph is going to
mimic
play in the formula game
so making the moves in that graph are
going to correspond to setting variables
true and false because the graph is
going to be specially designed to to
force that behavior
okay so i think we have a check-in
coming in yeah so let's just see how
um i i suggest you pay attention to this
check-in and really try to think about
it and solve it because i think that'll
help you make the connection between the
truth
of the formula and
exist
having a winning strategy
okay so
so if you take this formula here here's
you know this is some particular formula
exist x for all y blah blah blah
um this is going to be associated to
that formula a formula game
where first exist moves
assigns a value for x and depending upon
that value for all is going to move and
they're going to assign a value for y
and after that's done this part here is
either going to be true or false it's
either going to be satisfied or
unsatisfied
and i want to know can exist always find
a way can it does
to to guarantee that this part is going
to be satisfied or can for all always
get find a way to guarantee that this
part is not satisfied
okay so it's you have to stare you have
to look at this
uh formula to understand
which side is going to end up succeeding
um
so you understand you have to if you're
not clear on the rules look back here
exist is trying to make this part
satisfied for all is trying to make this
part unsatisfied but they neither of
them has the no the totally upper hand
because existence depicting one of the
variables for all is picking the other
variable
but they're doing it in a certain
order okay first exist is going to pick
then a for all is going to pick
okay so that's the way the game works
exist picks a value then for all picks a
value and then you see who wins
so who wins
who's guaranteed to win
um you know can can we make sure exist
always wins or can we make sure that it
for all always wins for this particular
formula so there's just two variables
here
and you can think about this in either
of two ways strictly speaking purely as
a game
or you can look at understand whether
that formula is true or not
um
they're equivalent ways of looking at at
the problem
in fact in a certain sense it's the same
that's what i'm trying to
trying to get across
thinking about this as a game or
thinking about in terms of quantifiers
doesn't make any difference um
okay
almost done here
so
all right
last call
closing the poll
okay i think this one you got
you you you did pretty well on so yeah
the correct answer is the for all player
has a uh winning strategy has a forced
win
uh
and um also similarly the
expression um is
fee is is false
because you know if you try to find some
x
such that no matter what y you pick
um this is going to be true
this is going to be satisfied you're out
of luck because you know if you make x
true
well um
then
if you make x
true
now i'm confused uh
what is going on if you make x true then
uh
y
oh if you make x true
then uh x bar is false
um so y bar has to be true
uh
um
now i'm completely confused oh no
if make x true it has to work for all y
so this thing is clearly false if you
make x true
um
uh then then
then this x bar is going to be false and
it's not the case that for every y
of the setting for y because y is forced
here y is going to have to be true
well y bar is going to have to be true
so y is going to have to be false
somebody if you make
it very clearly but if you make if you
and now if you if you try again
to make x false
um
maybe that's a one to think about first
if you make x false
so
you're going to be stuck on the first
clause because you have it has to work
for both settings of y
but maybe thinking about it as a game is
better you know if you
no matter what x does a y is going to
find have a way of
making one of those two clauses
unsatisfied so if x is true why can uh
uh can set itself like why we can set y
to make the second clause
uh unsatisfied and if x is false we can
find y can be assigned to make the first
clause unsatisfied
um
so anyway um
the right answer is uh the for all
player uh has a winning strategy here in
the end of the day it's not critical
that you understand this correspondence
but
but you have to then if you don't quite
understand that you're going to have to
take on faith
that the formula game is the same as
tqbf
because that's we're going to use and by
the way i would like to also mention
here that um
that this correspondence between
uh games and quantifiers is some things
that mathematicians use all the time
um
because if you have a if you have some
expression which comes up often in
mathematics where there are you know a
whole run of quantifiers you know in
front of some
uh some statement
it's really kind of hard for anybody uh
to really uh
get a feeling for what that means
if you have like six alternating
quantifiers which happens often in
mathematics you're going to have
statements that have a lot of
alternations with quantifiers very hard
to get a feeling for what that means but
if you think about it as a game it's
much more intuitive and it's completely
equivalent to think about quantifiers go
back and forth between quantifiers and
games
anyway um so let's
look at the at the reduction the the
construction that shows uh generalized
geography is uh complete took a little
longer than i thought maybe this is i
just want to make sure everybody's with
me on this so why don't we call the
break now
and then we'll come back
um and we'll look at the construction um
after that because the construction
itself is going to take about 10 minutes
to to work through to figure out how to
reduce
tqbf
and build a graph that simulates the
formula
okay so i'm going to move
right on to uh
the um
and we'll come back
okay so feel free to ask some questions
um
and uh
get ready for us diving in to a
construction
uh for the um
uh for the reduction of tqbf to
generalize geography
so
there's kind of an interesting question
about
you know
what's a relationship
you know between a formula and when you
swap the order of the quantifiers um
uh you know the the the the question is
asking does that somehow relate to the
negating the um
the you know the part the quantifier
free part the part without the
quantifiers and i um i don't think that
that's the right correspondence there it
actually is
uh some relationship when you say um
you know there exists for all is
actually a stronger statement than than
saying that for all there exists in
general the um
that actually implies you know exist x
for a why is this
implies uh
for a why there exists an x um because
what you're saying is that there is
the the choice of y
if
there exists an x
uh for all y there was one x that works
for every one of the y's if you're
saying for y there exists an x the
choice of that x can depend on the y
um
so there
there is a connection but um you have to
think through what it means in order to
understand that connection
not i think you won't need to know that
in order to process what we're going to
be doing but maybe it just helps you
think about it
um
other questions here
okay i think we're
um
we're out of time here
so let's
return to
our
our lecture
um
so i'm gonna go back
hopefully that won't
crash everything
[Music]
here we go
okay so now we're going to be reducing
tqbf
to generalize geography are we all
together now
um
uh
okay
so i'm gonna
illustrate this construction which is
very nice construction by the way i'm
gonna illustrate this construction just
by doing an example or a partial
example okay but i think it'll give you
the idea
so you understand so what i'm trying to
do here is i'm starting off with a
quantified boolean formula
so here it is
um i'm going to assume it's in
conjunctive normal form
which i can always
convert it into that form uh maybe by
adding some additional variables but
without
doing anything
too drastic to it
and so now what i'm gonna uh
starting from that formula
i'm gonna now build a graph
we're playing the geography game on that
graph which is remember taking turns
picking nodes which may form a path
is going to correspond to um
playing the formula game which is
picking the variables of that formula
and then you want uh the
if the exist player wins in the formula
then player one is supposed to win
in the geography game
okay
um
so here is how the graph is going to
look okay so good to follow try to
follow this um
so it's going to be
kind of there's going to be kind of two
parts one that's going to
correspond to the variables and the
other part that's going to correspond to
the clauses
um
and so for each variable i'm going to
have like a diamond structure here so
there's a little starting thing that's
going to be unique to the to the first
variable but then
every variable is going to have like a
little diamond structure here um and
they're going to be attached one to the
next
and we'll to understand how this what
this means
when we play
geography
on this piece of the graph
so but let's just understand the
structure first
okay
so this is the start node
and now um
here i'm player one is going to play the
role of exist player two is going to
play the role of parole and in fact i'm
going to identify that so i'm going to
call because it's going to be helpful
just to have
uh
helpful just to
think about player 1 is being the exist
player so the exist player is going to
be playing on this graph
the exist and the for all players are
going to be playing on this graph it's
really just players one and two
so exist the exist player player one
has to
b
by the rules has to pick the start note
and now with player two's move these the
four players move
now
if you're with me
on this graph
the for all for the for all players move
um is now not very interesting because
it's forced
it has to go to here because again
they're just picking
the
um
the nodes of a simple path
in this graph so
for the fraud
player to the for all player has to go
here is if exist started over there
now um now it's now it's the exist
player's turn
and now now something interesting
happens the exist player has a choice
you can either go left or right
there are two possibilities
and then
after that
the four player's turn
who's again just forced so so far for
all has not had much interesting stuff
to do in this hasn't has not had to have
has not had to think hard
um
so for all players
no matter whether exists went left or
right the for all players move is forced
and ends up over here
and now let's see if this player's turn
again this is kind of an easy one
oh so before i do that let's just look
at how that play could go
so the first two moves that's kind of i
was suggesting exist goes here and then
for all goes there
i'm gonna i'm gonna illustrate
kind of possible plays through this
graph by tracing them out in green
um
so now exists goes here for all goes
there those those were forced but now
the exist player goes could either go
this way
or
could go that way
so those are two
possible different
ways of playing this the game that we
said we're building
um
and now
uh now whose turn is it here
this was the for all player pick this
one so the the the next turn is the
exist player and that's forced
but now
notice now for the first time the for
all player has to think because the for
all player can either go left or right
so could either go left or it could go
right
um
and so
then there's going to be a sequence of
these diamond structures where
kind of they're constructed so that
alternately either the exist has a
choice or the for all player has a
choice
until you get all the way down to the
bottom
okay
that is the graph we've built so far now
if we stopped here
um
then
whoever ended up at this point whether
it was existing for all would be the
winner because there's nowhere for the
other for the opponent to go of course
that wouldn't be very interesting
so there's going to be more stuff we're
going to add on which are going to
correspond to the clauses
now
how to think about what's happened so
far
now so maybe as some of you might be
guessing
is that um when the exist player over
here has a choice could have either gone
left or right that's going to correspond
because this is supposed to be
mimicking the formula game that's going
to correspond to the
uh
exist player
in the formula picking the variable
either true or false
so that the left or right is going to
correspond to true or false
and so um let's just arbitrarily say
left is going to correspond to picking
it true
and right is going to correspond to
picking false
okay so that
so the way i've said it so far is
exist ended up picking the first
variable false then for all pick the
second variable false
and the empty variable also got set
folds everything got set for so far who
knows what happened over here of course
um
uh
okay so just to understand what we've
done so far
now i'm going to show you how to build
the rest of the graph so let's take away
the green part um and now we're just
back to the construction
the green part is actually how you use
that construction so back to the
construction here now what do we want to
achieve
now by the time the
the players on the graph have got down
to here they've effectively made an
assignment to the variables by going
either left or right at each one of
these diamonds so the assignment is done
from the game from the perspective of
the formula game the game is over and
now one side or the other has one
here
we want to build some extra structure
here as a kind of an end game
to make sure
that
the for all player gets stuck
if the exist player has made an
assignment which satisfies the formula
satisfies this part of the formula
and
the exist player should get stuck
if the for all player if the assignment
that they made
does not satisfy the form
okay so let's see how we're going to
achieve that with some additional
structure
so
there's going to be some extra node over
here
let me just tell you what the structure
is and then we'll argue why it works
so there's going to be
going from this bottom node we're going
to start a kind of
you know
the second part of the graph there's
going to be a node which
fans out to a node for each one of the
clauses
and each one of those clauses in turn
fans out to a node for each one of its
literals
so you see we have clause c1
and it has the literals x1 x2 bar x3 x1
x2 bar x3
so there's no note for each of the
literals and clause c1 same for clause
c2
and so on
now we're almost done
now i'm going to tell you how to connect
up these literal nodes
so x1 each node is going to get
correspond
back to
its own diamond so now we're going to
tie it back to the the first part where
we made the assignment the assignment
part of the graph
x1 is going to connect back to the true
part of the x1 diamond
and x2 because it's negated is going to
tie back to the false part of the x2
diamond
because it's an x2 variable
similarly x1 bar
now in
you know in
because x1 bar
you know here's x1 bar and clause 2.
x1 bar
is going to connect up now to the full
side of the x1 diamond
and x2 bar is going to connect up to the
full side of the x2 diamond
and so on so if we had i don't have the
other diamonds here but the x4 would
connect up to the true side of the x4
diamond
for example
that's the whole construction let's
understand why it works
okay so the end game here is we want
exist to win
um
if the assignment satisfied all the
clauses
and for all should win if there was some
unsatisfied clause
okay so why why does this happen so
let's put back an assignment here that
was made so here's here for the in the
one i'm i'm putting back is
you know the assignment that they
cooperatively built
had x1 being true
x2 being false
and some other stuff
now why does this work so what we want
to have happen now now so now the
move proceeds over to here and you need
to arrange it so that exists
is the one who picks that note
if you have a um if you know if you you
know
if this would have been for all just add
an extra node to switch who's
whose turn it is
but you want exist to be up here and
what you want is for all to be picking
the clause
the clause note
now here is
here's the part to understand what's
going on
um
we want
for all to win
if this is not
satisfied so the
for all is going to make a claim
um
if this is not satisfied there is some
clause which is not satisfied there's
some clause which ended up being false
in the assignment so
the for all player gonna say i think i
won
and i won because clause number one is
unsatisfied
so it's going to pick clause number one
so here's the four players more going
his exist player
and so
the four player picks the clause claimed
unsatisfied so over here
full player says claude c1 is
unsatisfied i'm going to move here
if this player says
i don't agree with you the assignment
you know your your line um
uh
the
assignment actually makes one of the
literals true in clause c1
let's say it made x1 was true
as it as in fact it is here x1 in fact
is true so
exist is now
its turn it's going to pick the the
literal that was true
in the assignment in that clause
that the fraud player is claiming is
unsatisfied
one of them is lying at this point
this is either now true in here which
means a for all player did not pick an
unsatisfied clause or the exist player
picked a false literal which is the the
the exist player picked the false letter
over to the exist players lie
so now we're gonna now
the moment of truth
because
let's see if exist gold picked here
now it's um the for all's players turn
it's connected back to the true side of
the diamond
so that node was already used that's the
only place that for all could possibly
go for all is stuck
and an exist has won the game which is
what you want
because
um
for all claims are false and the and the
exist was was was was correct in saying
that x1 satisfied clause c1
so x1 is true
so um there's nowhere for for all to go
but compare that with the situation if
the assignment on this part of the graph
had gone through the false
had assigned x1 to be false
so the path had gone through the full
side of the diamond
now this node would still be unoccupied
would still be um
available
so now the for role play so if if exist
was claiming that x1 was true and it
really was false
the fraud player would be able to move
on to that node and now it's the exist
player's turn and the exist would be
stuck because
this node down here is guaranteed to
have been used
okay so that
is the idea
it's really very beautiful um
and actually not that complicated you
have to you have to stare at it a bit so
let's just see what happens for example
if um
i had one other case maybe it's not
necessary at this point um but you know
if the for all player claimed
well
it's the second clause which is
unsatisfied in the
mutually selected assignment um
then
uh
so this is sort of the the case where
the for all players is correct um you
know in in that if the exist player now
says well i think x1 bar satisfied that
uh second clause
but you know this
assignment made x1 true so x1 bar is
false and so the exist player is lying
this time
and so now the for all player can take
this last edge and go here
and has one one last move to make and
then the exist player stuck
so the for all will win in that case
so let's turn now shifting gears
entirely
to a different um
uh
part of the spate you know
of space complexity instead of looking
at polynomial space which is like very
powerful we're going to look at log
space which is comparatively speaking
much much weaker
so log space are the things that you can
do when you only have
enough space to write down essentially a
pointer or some fixed number of pointers
into the input that's what you get when
you have logarithmic space
and
you know because log space is enough to
write down an index of something um so
you can just this is what you can do
with a bunch of pointers
and
in order to make sense of this we have
to change the model of computation
because if we use the ordinary one tape
turing machine
just scanning across the input
will
just reading the input with the way
we've defined it would cost space n
and so you can't even read the input
if you have less than n space available
like log space
so we're going to introduce a different
model just
to allow us to define this
and that's a model where it's going to
be have two tapes
where the part that contains the input
doesn't count
and that's in order to make sure it
doesn't you know it's not being cheated
the the input tape is going to be read
only
um but it doesn't count toward the space
used only the work tape
which is now has can read can be read or
or written or red
is going to count toward the space bound
okay
um
so now what we're going to define is
you know
using this definition for
our space complexity
um
we'll define
space log n
the things that you can do if you have
only a log amount of space here
on the work tape
so the length of the input is n
the length of the um
of the work tape is lo order log n
so we have uh the deterministic and
non-deterministic associated classes uh
space log n and n space log n we're
calling that l and n l
log space and not deterministic log
space
okay um and as i said that's just enough
space to write down some pointers into
the input and let's do some quick
examples
um
so if you take the language of
palindromes essentially or ww reverse um
that's
in log space uh
so here is a string i don't know i was
here's a string that's in www reverse
and
i mean the ordinary way you might use to
test whether a string is of this form in
ww reverse might be to cross off
corresponding locations here but you
can't do that it's a read-only input
tape so you have to somehow avoid
writing on the input tape but still
testing whether you're in this language
it's not hard to do you can use the work
tape just to keep track of where your
pointers would be
um
and
in so doing you can just
make sure you're
matching off corresponding locations
with each other in the input
so log space because of its ability to
store some fixed number of pointers
it gives you enough to test membership
in this language
so this is in this is solvable in log
space
uh
the path problem which we've seen before
you know you're given a graph and a
start node and
an ending node or a start and a target
you're given a graph of an s and t
it's a directed graph and you know can i
know can i get from s to t
um so that problem is solvable in
non-deterministic log space
uh because as
um the way we would do that i'm not not
writing this down in in any detail but
uh what you would do in your
um not you know non-deterministic log
space machine you have your input graph
written here in the input
and you're just going to guess the
sequence of
nodes
one by one which takes you from the
start node to the target node
you're not going to write down that
whole sequence because that in advance
because that would be
cost you way too much space to write
down the only space that you're going to
use is to remember the current location
we are sitting
so you start out you know you write down
on the work tape the start node
then you're going to
non-deterministically pick one of the
outgoing edges from the start node and
look at its associated node and replace
that on your work tape and keep keep
repeating that if you ever get to the
node t then you can accept
and you also have to be a little careful
i don't have this on on the slide you
also have to make sure that if the graph
has a loop in it
or because that's not allowed in space
complexity uh so you're going to need
also a counter to make sure that if you
count up to a um you've you you you
you've gone through a number of nodes
which exceeds the total number of nodes
in the graph
uh then you can shut down that branch of
the non-determinism uh because
you know it's
you know just it's just going in
a loop
um
if there's any path that connects s to t
there's certainly going to be a path
that has at most the number of nodes of
the graph in it
okay um so path is in nl this language
here is an in l um
what's the relationship between l and n
l well certainly the deterministic class
is contained in the non-deterministic
class
that's all that's known
whether these two collapse down to be
the same
is unsolved and so we're going to spend
a little time next lecture exploring
this
um but but let's let's first
look at some of the basic facts about
log space
um sort of setting ourselves up for next
lecture
so
first of all anything that you can do in
log space you can do in polynomial time
in a sense kind of trivially and in a
sense we almost kind of really proved
this already because if you remember
we said that anything that you can do in
a certain amount of space you can
do
in that much
uh you can do
in time
in
that's exponential in the amount of
space
in the corresponding amount of space so
going from space to time blows you up
exponentially
and
order log the exponential of order log n
is polynomial
so the way we're going to prove this
and again we kind of proved this already
but let's just go through it again
specific to
log space
uh we'll say and this is going to be a
useful definition for us anyway um
a configuration for m on w so we would
also we already talked about a
configuration of turing machine m which
is just a snapshot which is the tape
the state and the head position
when we have
an
input which is sort of an uh read-only
input which is not being counted toward
the space we don't include that in the
configuration um we just say
it's a configuration of m on that
particular input but we're going to be
counting configurations and i don't want
to count all the different inputs as
well i'm going to fix the input and
count all of the configurations relative
to that input
and
so the number of such configurations is
just simply going to be
the number of states times the number of
head positions for the two
heads now
times the number of possible tape
contents and which as i mentioned here
is the number of different possible tape
contents
it's d which is the tape alphabet to the
order log n and that's just going to be
n to the k for some k so it's going to
be polynomial so that tells us
that because the total number of
configurations
um
for m on w is polynomial
this machine
can only be running for a polynomial
number of steps otherwise it will be
looping people are repeating a
configuration and so therefore
that machine has to run itself in
polynomial time so you don't really in a
sense have to do any work if a machine
is deterministically designing a
language in log space
it's also deterministically deciding the
language in polynomial time because
that's all the time you can use when you
have log space unless you're looping
which is not allowed okay so therefore
the same machine shows that you're also
in pain
oh
i'll get to that in a second one thing i
forgot to mention on the previous slide
when i'm talking about the model is by
the way this model is not so
unreasonable um
where you have kind of a imagine having
a very large read-only input
and and your local storage is much
smaller it's much too small to pull in
the entire input
the way i used to explain this
years ago was like you have a your input
is a cd-rom which you guys probably
barely even
know what it is anymore but used to
distribute software that way so the rom
was like on a dvd uh or cd
which contain your
whatever you're trying to like yourself
whether you're trying to distribute
you know it was some large thing uh
relatively and so
you would imagine having a smaller
amount of
memory relative to that so you didn't
want to necessarily copy that whole
thing into your storage
maybe even a better example now is like
you think of the input as being the
entire internet
um obviously you can't download unless
you're google you can't download
the whole internet into your own uh
local memory
but you're going to have references
pointers into the input into different
places that's perhaps more analogous to
this sort of read-only input touring
machine model that i'm describing um
okay
uh
so
um
and it's another fact i want to mention
is that i'm not going to
savage just the anything that you can do
non-deterministic log space you can do
in deterministic
uh space but now with a squaring
and that's using the same proof that's
using savage's theorem which you have to
check also works down to log space
same proof
um
so anything that you do not
deterministically in log n space you can
use deterministically log squared n
space
okay so let me just see if there's a
couple of questions i want to answer
here
[Music]
the relationship between
l and nl is not known to be strict
nobody knows of an example no one knows
whether they're equal
and
and have people looked at
um
sublinear time classes
yes generally for
when you have non-deterministic or
probabilistic which we're not haven't
defined yet but we will um people have
looked at um those sub-linear time
classes as well deterministically
doesn't make so much sense because then
you can't even talk about
either the whole input um
okay uh let me move on um
okay so this this is my last slide let
me see if we can do this before we break
um not only is l contained within p but
this much stronger statement is that nl
is contained within p and that we you'll
that for that you'll have to do some
work because converting your
non-deterministic log space machine to a
deterministic
machine
um obviously you're going to have to
change the machine um
and so we'll introduce a new method here
maybe we'll
quickly go over this at the beginning of
the next lecture
i don't like rushing through things at
the end
but for this
if i if i'm given
um
a non-deterministic machine
that runs in log space
i want to make a new machine that runs
in polynomial time deterministically for
the same language
and i'm going to define something called
the configuration graph for m on an
input w
and that's just you take
m
and it's and w
its input and you look at all of the
configurations
um
for m w actually configuration graph
actually that's
should be called the computation graph
that's what it's called in the book but
okay this is a typo yeah i'll fix that
next time
uh it doesn't matter computation graph
configuration will graph uh all the same
basically you're going to take all of
the configurations of m on w of which we
already observed
only number or only polynomial in number
and may they become the nodes of a graph
and the edges connect two configurations
if one follows another according to the
rules of the machine
okay so here's a picture
these are
ins this is some graph the nodes of this
graph are the configurations of m on w
right so each node here corresponds to
the machine a snapshot of the machine
a
tape contents head position and state
so writing down all those different
configurations i connect one to the
other if i can get to cj cj from ci in
one step legally on the machine
and then
uh
the non-deterministic machine m accepts
w
exactly when there's a path from the
start configuration to the to to to an
accept configuration let's assume we
have just a single accept configuration
as we argue we can do
one or two lectures back
um if we clean up the tapes
so
testing whether you can get from the
start to the accept um
uh is the same as testing whether the
machine accepts its input
and so
because we can test
whether there's a path in a graph
connecting two nodes in polynomial time
we can solve this problem on this
computation configuration graph in
polynomial time and so we can figure out
whether the non-deterministic machine
accepts its input
sorry that came a little faster than i
like to do so we'll we'll we'll see it
again um so here's the polynomial time
algorithm
you construct the graph
you accept if there's a path from the
star to the accept and you reject it
does not
um
and so that tells us that
not only is l contained with an nl but
nl itself is also contained within p so
here's that here's a kind of a nice
hierarchy of languages
we don't not only do we not know whether
l equals n l we don't know whether l
equals p
it's possible that anything you can do
in polynomial time you can do
deterministically in log space shocking
as that might be because it's a pretty
weak class
but we don't know how to prove that uh
there's anything different
anything in p that's not in here
um last check in
uh so we showed that path is in nl
what's the best thing we can do about
the deterministic space complexity of
path so deterministic so this is
non-deterministic log space what can we
say deterministically
about path um
hint
this should not be this should not be
hard
uh if you think back to what we've
shown very recently
okay
get your check in points closing up
closing stop here
all set one two three
yes so the correct answer is log squared
space because this is just savages there
we can do it in log space
non-deterministically so you can do it
in log squared space deterministically
okay so that's um this is what we did
today
um
and i as i mentioned i will uh do this
again
on at tuesday's lecture just to recap
that
all right so i'll stick around a little
bit for questions and um
okay someone says to be about the
nomenclature
why is it l in l space
um
i you know
because there's not really people don't
usually talk about l time so l is sort
of
everybody knows it's the only reasonable
option is space so people just say l and
then l
um
i mean some of these things have had
you know
you know these things these names have a
little bit evolved over time and even
now some people say talk about uh
um
you know i call time classes some call
some people call it d time classes
you know it's just you know it
uh you can make different choices there
um
okay uh let's see
good
um
why does savage's theorem work for log n
you have to you have to look back and
see what you needed
um
and all you needed to be able to do
was to um
write down
uh the configurations
um
and uh if you look back at how savage's
theorem works you're just needing to
write down the configuration so the
deterministic machine can write down the
configurations for the non-deterministic
machine they take exactly the same
size
and then you look at the recursion
and the the depth of the recursion is
going to be exponential
in um the size of the configurations and
so you're going to end up with a
squaring again you have to go back and
just
rethink that proof and you'll see
nowhere did it need a linear amount of
space it works down to a lot it actually
does not work for less than log n
log n is sort of the lower threshold
there
and the reason for that is because you
also need to store the
input location
and that already takes log space
uh the you know not the
the the the head tape heads the tape
heads already kind of
um
have kind of a log space aspect to them
and so
if you're going to you use less than log
space then funky things happen with the
tape head storing the tape heads and so
less than log space usually turns out
not to be interesting
very specific to turing machines and not
sort of general general models
yeah so somebody's asking
suppose in the reduction um
to generalize geography from tqbf if the
formula had two exists in a row
um then you would do kind of the natural
thing in the graph instead of having
that spacer edge between the two
diamonds you could just have one diamond
connecting directly to the other diamond
without a spacer edge
and that would be give you the effect
of
not switching whose turn it is
uh somebody's asking me just a general
question
are people thinking about
these open problems
um
i don't know
people don't don't don't say um
there was a lot of work
on problems related that seemed to be
related to those
those many open questions like p versus
np
l versus nl or l versus p and so on p
versus p space
we'll say we'll talk a little bit more
about some of that there's some very
interesting things that have been
developed i think there's a sense within
the community
that people are stuck
and it's not something you're going to
need some sort of major new
uh idea in order to push the thing
forward so i don't know how many people
are still thinking about them
i hope people are because i would like
to see the answer at some point but
or get the answer
i think about them sometimes myself but
one has to acknowledge
chances of success are not high
uh
okay um
so we're a little after past the end of
the hour here um unless there's any
other questions if i didn't answer your
question i may have missed it so you can
ask again
um
but otherwise i'm going to
close this close the session here
okay bye bye all have a good weekend see
you next week
take care
you